so do you think that
um
that culture
and be shifted back towards
um respect and Authority or do you think
the strategy for men is to
um kind of sort of say yep look the
culture is [__] so I need to basically
optimize for being [__] by the culture
because this shit's not going to change
if you live in the west it's the latter
I'm a I'm a I'm more of a enjoy the
decline sort of guy
um like like what I do with my content
with my videos with my podcast with my
book like what I've basically done is
I've is I've drafted a a big ass map of
the world and I've plotted where the
landmines are on it I say walk through
the world just don't step in these areas
right
um so you can have a good experience as
a guy you can deal with women you could
potentially even have children if if you
take the appropriate measures and and
steps in your life to minimize risk
exposure and understand the landscape
that you're dealing with but you know
the question of is society going to
improve and kind of normalize back to
the ways you know that it were
um I don't see that happening the trend
that I see is more woke is a more
liberalism like I watched um Matt
Walsh's
um special
um what is a woman there's a woman yeah
since I subscribed to the Daily wire to
watch that Jordan Peterson thing I
thought I would check that out too and
by the end of watching that it's a
90-minute special and I think you know
what it's about it's about
um transgenderism and a whole bunch of
other you know components that are tied
into this notion that you can't Define
what a woman is today I was that feeling
like I don't belong in this world right
like the way that things are going in
the west are not for me I happen to live
here I'm I'm kind of stuck here because
I'm tied here you know with family uh
raising a kid I've got business
Investments and interests here but my
long-term plan for me is to more or less
exit the West at least 50 percent of the
time like I don't even want to spend my
Winters here it's it's cold in Canada in
the winter sort of thing but there's
places in the world where it's it's
better for men you know like I'll say
this like you will be treated treated
better as a man in different places the
world and you can mobilize you know you
don't have to like this is not 2 000
years ago where it would take you three
months to row a [__] Viking ship
across the ocean right like this is
modern times you can you can buy a
ticket for a thousand bucks fly to
another part of the world and create
yourself a location Independent Business
just run it from there and if that
doesn't work out over there you can move
to another part of the world you know
sort of thing
um you can mobilize in today's world so
there's so there's tools and strategies
that you can use as a guy to have a good
experience to put yourself first and you
know make sure that you get what you
want out of life
so when you when you're saying you know
I don't belong here I was actually
I was having a conversation with a
friend uh the other week and I was
saying the same thing but I was kind of
saying I think I'm born in the wrong
[__] Century um or the wrong
Millennium like the I just find it hard
to relate to whether it's the Lemmings
or just the the lack of
I don't know like [__] courage and
will in humanity these days it's um
it's concerning but there's a there's a
general pacification of the West going
on I don't know a better way to describe
it other than the pussification of the
West it's happening it's real it's it's
a very slow moving grinding machine but
it's but it's generally moving in the
direction of softening men
um turning women into terrible versions
of men
um destroying the fabric of society like
I get why Jordan Peterson says get
married you know it's you know it's a
Bedrock of society blah blah blah okay
but you're not talking risk mitigation
you're not talking about the reality
things and I look at the entire scope of
things with everything even sitting in
the blind spots of most people because
there's a lot like you know I see about
this far
after that it's all in my blind spot so
there's all this [__] behind us you know
it's like the whole you don't know what
you don't know and most people willfully
Walks Like sleep walk through life you
know they're not paying attention to you
know the code in The Matrix they don't
want to unplug they they just want to
get up in the morning go to work earn
their paycheck come home hope their wife
is going to bang them they try to make
an advance doesn't happen they deal with
the [__] in their house and they go and
rinse and repeat the next day and pay
their taxes and enrich government state
institutions and give up their freedoms
willingly
without any protest you know we saw it
happen during the last scandemic where
people willingly stood on dots and were
taking vaccinations because if they
didn't they would lose their job
willingly people willingly folded to the
entire narrative without asking any
questions I was one of the few people
that was asking questions going wait
hold on a second you can go back to my
YouTube channel two three months after
the whole thing started I started
talking about it on my YouTube channel
broadly I was I was very careful because
I knew that they were going to silence
people but I but I broadly started
talking about it then like why aren't we
asking questions why are people just
doing these things why is everybody so
easily you know following the narrative
right why is this all of a sudden so
safe and effective after no trials or no
years of research and treatment right
and it's like here I am and I was right
you know like I watched I watched
everything unfold exactly the way that I
but people don't ask questions today
they just
your taxes yes comply you know Bitcoin
is [__] okay so don't don't buy that do
this yeah okay so stand on the dot yeah
so get the jab they just comply with
everything right they don't think they
don't ask questions and critical
thinking is a lost art today
um
a buddy of mine once said the movie
Idiocracy I don't know if you've seen it
yeah you said it's not a fictional movie
he said it's a documentary this is
exactly what's unfolding
it totally is bro but it's like it's a
it's like idiocracy meets The Twilight
Zone because it's like [__] weird as
well bro it's like it's yeah it's like
it's like a mixed episode of Black
Mirror Twilight Zone and freaking
idiocracy man it's and I here I am on my
Island you know talking to like the
random guy like you that like gets it
all right or the odd guy that like reads
my books and watches my video and
they're like dude you saved my life
right it's it's
it's it's very very difficult work
unplugging Society from The Matrix and
they don't want you doing it right I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out